bundy who has now pitching for the first
time to what people thought he would be
when he was drafted fourth overall many
years ago he's healthy and it'd be
hard to believe that he would finish
this year in an angels uniform j.p
crawford steps in swinging a line shot
down the right field side and this one
is on the track and bounces over the
short wall in the corner
for a ground rule double and jp crawford
leads off the ball game with an extra
base hit the next batter will be sam
hagerty 3-2 he did go with the off-speed
pitch one away that'll bring up center
fielder kyle lewis lewis gets champ
rolls one towards short simmons no slow
roller only goes to first base albert
able to keep the foot on the base two
down crawford ends up at third that'll
bring up kyle seeger that's out toward
left field justin upton has to go back
on it
he's there puts it away and they end up
leaving a runner at third and on the
bound getting ready for his sixth start
of the year left-hander justice
sheffield first batter he'll face
tonight will be david fletcher 3-2 to
fletcher swing and a miss and a slider
down and in for strike three already his
first strikeout first batter that he
faces there's designated hitter shoei
ohtani swing and a miss and a curveball
for strike three so back to back
strikeouts for justice sheffield
two up and two down for the angels
that'll bring up center fielder mike
trout cued up the first base line
sheffield will pick it up spin around
flip it over to marmalades and it hits
trout it trickles out into shallow
trout will have to go back to first base
now stay there at first base after
making the commitment to go to second
the trout's safe at first that'll bring
up anthony rendon and the next delivery
this ball is lined into left center
field and it's over the head of hagerty
route is going into third he's going to
be waived home and that's going to be a
two-out rbi double by rendon and the
angels have a one-nothing lead so one on
and one away and the mariners have the
time run aboard for designated hitter
tim lopes down the line that's a fair
ball now tie this game up marmalades can
take his time coming home rbi double tim
lopes new ball game here in the second
now the mariners have two on in scoring
position second and third with two outs
this is popped in the air into left
center field the shortstop simmons goes
back falls
off upton and trouty was coming in and
andrewton makes the catch up with a
leadoff walk here in the bottom of the
second that'll bring up rookie right
fielder joe adele joey looking for that
first career home run sheffield has not
allowed a home run this year that ball's
emptied high and it's hit deep down the
left field side it is way out of here
joe adele you were just talking about
sheffield not giving up a home run this
season that is adele's first big league
homer and it was a no doubter for
437 feet that's one of many you're going
to see from jodell in his career now the
angels have runners on it first and
second with one out brings up designated
hitter shohei ohtani strike three called
he got him looking with a pitch right at
the knees that's the third time that
sheffield sheffield's banned
shohei ohtani that is strikeout number
six for sheffield two on and two out and
that will bring up mike trout
walk to face of the loader for rendell a
couple of walks served up by sheffield
here in the bottom of the fifth inning
and he walked out great at that by
window didn't chase that breaking ball
that will force in simmons
from third base and the angels now lead
it 4-1 so albert steps up with runners
everywhere ground ball toward the middle
shed long junior can't get there that'll
bring home two six one halos albert
delivers still two outs and that'll
bring up justin upton there's the pit
swung on ground ball up the middle way
to his right to backhand and shed long
and the other side of the bag long throw
to first long reach marmalaos in time
what a play by shed long two outs
hagerty and scoring position here is
nola
back toward the middle simmons with a
diving stop gets up fires to first
alberts lake did he dig it out and keep
the foot on he did battle the hell pools
who's able to do that what a play by
both simba and pools that baseball was
by him gets up and fires it albert's got
to find the bag and reach out and his
foot is on the bag aaron fletcher is up
on the mound for the mariners facing joe
adele and this ball here is hit well
into right center field that one is out
by the wall in right center field and
that ball is out of here
joe adele
second home run of the night runners at
the corners two outs for mike trout
trout hitting 400 four homers and six
runs batted in so far this season
against samaritan's liner in the right
center that's going to fall in roll all
the way out to the warning track two rbi
double for trout make it nine to one
angels mike trout doing damage again
what else is new
it's 11-1 angels jottle bound with two
in scoring position back-to-back
multi-hit games for trout breaking ball
that is driven out toward left field
headed to the bullpen gone
big fly for mike trout a three-hit game
and just another home run versus seattle
for trout it's 14-1 and the mariners
have two outs here in the top of the
ninth inning here's the pitch fastball
swung on fly ball well hit right center
field going and going and goodbye
baseball above the hedges in right
center field shed long with his third
home run of the season 2-2
got him light that baby up as the angels
pick up the victory 16-3 the final